Jaguar unveiled its first-ever SUV in
May and since then things have been
looking up for the formerly stuffy
British brand the company says the SUV
accounted for half of its US sales in
July so what's got people flocking to
this new cat I found a lot to discover
when I took the S case for a spin around
New York City I drove the F pace our
sport which starts at $54,000 but will
run you close to 64,000 with upgrades it
has a 340 horsepower supercharged v6
engine it's no Porsche Cayenne Turbo S
but it will get you to 60 miles per hour
in five four seconds top speed is 155
miles per hour
the steering standard all-wheel drive
and 8-speed automatic transmission ours
like a young jumping cat the exterior of
the car is exciting to choose the
metallic British racing green that my
car had it costs an extra few hundred
dollars but with the extremely fair
pricing on this thing you can afford it
jag has kept the wide rounded lattice
grill and the flashy red Jaguar logos it
also has stretched the body of the rig
long enough so that it looks lean and
mean ready to pounce this is no beefy
beer-drinking grit
it's a spelt jungle feline inside the
best part is the massive panoramic
sunroof big sunroof expands basically
the entire ceiling of the car it adds a
lot of natural light it makes it some
really big without increasing the
wheelbase at all
I congratulate jack for giving us
well-made leather top seats intuitive
controls and even ambient mood lighting
the touchscreen is nice and long and it
works well I'd love to see a better
resolution bill on the exterior cameras
and then there are the doors the lofts
and the window controls they're on two
different levels the bottom line jaguar
has a hit at least a triple with the F
pace it's stylish athletic and eager on
the road have you driven a Jaguar lately
if you haven't make it this one